well remember that Judge Massey / handed
young correctional supervision as the
appropriate sentence sometime last year
so what we have here is not that strange
considering that direct imprisonment was
not imposed from the outset so unlike
the thoughts out there saying that he
received the lenient sentence to be out
on 10 months Tom in terms of our
Criminal Procedure Act that is exactly
what correctional supervision entails in
terms of section 2 761 I which is the
applicable sentencing option mercy by
imposed in this instance and what will
be the conditions of his deter well bail
once he gets out yeah what happens now
is the remainder of the five-year term
that Sheen post will now be served under
ordinary correctional supervision that
means that he will be under house arrest
he will have to undergo certain programs
obviously victim compensation might also
be on the table things like that it's a
kind of an umbrella symptoms so a lot of
strict rules will be imposed by the
Department of Corrections services but
for the remainder period after five
years in other words the four years and
two months that still needs to be done
that will be served outside of jail
under house arrest unless obviously the
state is successful in the appeal that
there should be heard during more or
less november this year in blue Fontaine
at our Supreme Court of Appeal but house
arrest means he can't leave it or go
about town or have access to a car he
literally has to stay in his home that
is correct what usually happens is they
can attend the your house at any time of
the day or night to come and check up on
you usually it entails that you must be
this beard over at a specific time in
the afternoon usually around about five
o'clock and then obviously you're not
entitled to leave home and this that is
for work purposes which means that you
must go to work back home working home
and that's it you're not allowed to go
outside the jurisdiction ille area of of
the magistrate magisterial area in other
words in this instance but
aurea unless obviously you have the
consent of the department and your
correctional supervision probation
officer what about visitors can you have
as many visitors as you like in these
circumstances yes obviously there's no
probation on that as a general rule that
the issue comes in that you're not in
that you're not entitled to live as a
free person because you're still under
sanction remember they still the
remainder period of the five years that
must be served however obviously the
they will be scrutinized scrutinize
ation of those members of the public and
family members that want to come and
visit it won't be a car to pass for
everybody to come and go as they please
us they will be strict ruse even in this
instance as well and and how about
access to firearms and obviously that
will be a big no-no you remember he was
also convicted on a second charge for
the discharging of a firearm at one of
the conditions that is automatically
applied in our firearms and ammunition
act is that you're not eligible to
possess a firearm unless the court
directs otherwise which in this instance
did not happen therefore for the rest of
his life he will not be eligible as a
general rule to have a fire on or even
to possess a firearm nevermind to
discharge firearms in the public and so
on